jordan for the past few years now
assassin's creed has been
doing some pretty heavy flirting with
becoming a
full-on rpg would you agree
i mean yeah pretty much but i have i
have a lot of questions about it because
valhalla looks like it's going gonna be
the most rpg one of the lot
so how many hours of assassin's creed
valhalla have you played i've played so
much lucy back in july back in july i
played
three hours and then before this last
preview i got to check out an
hour of the settlement and then i just
played
six hours of the game that comes
right after the prologue so i've seen
almost 10 hours of
this game so far i don't know why
ubisoft won't just give me a copy to
play
gotcha so you got to spend a good chunk
of time you got to see some of the
settlements
um so you've obviously written up a big
preview you can look at it right now on
gamespot.com
but i'm really interested in talking
about how settlements are going to work
and how they're going to affect the
overall gameplay
because investing into the world of
assassin's creed like
investing into your town or like you had
a homestead in three you had
monterregioni i'm absolutely butchered
that name
but like you've always had
there's been previous games where you
have had that feeling of investment and
seeing something grow and change over
time so how is the settlement stuff in
valhalla
different i would say the biggest
difference i think this time around
is that it's i wouldn't say mandatory
because you could
theoretically skip most of it but the
game
heavily encourages you to take part like
assassin's creed ii assassin's creed 3
as you said
assassin's creed 3 as you said like all
of these games before have had home
bases that you could join and talk to
people and invest resources but it was
kind of just all optional you could just
skip over it if you wanted to you
couldn't do any you could just choose to
skip all of the quests
but in valhalla it's almost like the
normandy in mass effect or skyhold in
dragon age
where you start in the settlement you go
to your war room you
pick your next objective it's like oh do
you want to go here and do this go here
and do this or go here and do this
you pick that you get on your horse you
get on your longboat you go out and you
do your journey you do raids you do
missions etc etc
and then you come back to the settlement
as to have like a
debrief of sorts and invest your
resources build up new buildings unlock
new
vendors talk to people have a romance or
two maybe there's like a decision you
have to
make because two people are fighting
over resources or something you have to
make an executive decision
and after that you pick your next quest
and you just repeat it over and over
again but you're always coming back to
that settlement the game is always
causing you to come back before going on
to your next journey it's not like
previous assassin's creed games you're
just kind of
wandering from point to point on the map
in some haphazard line
you've invoked some pretty special names
there you invoked
bioware you invoked dragon age and mass
effect
honestly like i looked at some of the
gameplay and god yeah
it's got the huge dragon age vibes to
the uh you know slamming a dagger down
on a map on a wooden table
kind of vibe but i mean let's talk about
kind of the evolution of assassin's
creed as a franchise because
you know way back in a like og
assassin's creed
it very much felt like its own unique
action
action-adventure
title and now in later iterations
specifically starting with origins it
very much feels like it's gone for that
witcher vibe
um and i'm not saying this to be
reductive at all like i actually kind of
enjoyed that
as a turning point for the franchise is
to see how the witcher
particular witcher 3 wild hunt has
inspired it
but now you're kind of saying stuff like
dragon age and mass effect so i want to
know if it still has those
kind of witcher vibes or if it's
changing course a little bit and to
become a
bit of a different kind of rpg it kind
of feels like it's going a little bit
away
from witcher vibes i feel a little bad
for assassin's creed we're like oh the
combat in origins is like dark souls and
it's like oh the exploration in odyssey
is like
uh the witcher now i'm kind of saying
like oh and valhalla kind of has a
little bit of dragon age inquisition
going on
and like it does have its own flavor it
has that same assassin's creed
flavor but while i was playing
valhalla in the six hours that i just
had with it there wasn't any of those
really long memorable
quests that i remembered from odyssey
the
side quests that would sometimes last
two
hours and introduce me to some
character who was really cool or
memorable in some way
and then kind of go on and do something
else like
very witcher 3 side quests and valhalla
kind of
seems to be going away from that a
little bit
there are still memorable quests but
they're more like
world events something that kind of
seems a bit more dragon agey
in a way like they're they're very
memorable but they're very short i could
finish
a vast majority of them in like two to
ten minutes like
this is going to sound weird like keep
up with me with this so there's this
lady i encountered in a sewer who wanted
me to bring her viper eggs
you heard me i need eggs viper eggs
crusty little sheets won't go away
and i killed a bunch of snakes brought
her the eggs
and she used that opportunity to fart in
my face
[Applause]
just like release a huge fart and then
when i went up to the city like everyone
was running away from all the sewer
grates because her fart had just
traveled throughout the sewer and was
like stinking up the whole town
and like on the same like sort of thing
like there was a quest where i just
ran into a girl who was begging for a
leaf to not fall from a tree
because she had said that three weeks
earlier her dad was going to town for
work
and he would be back before the last
leaf fell to the ground
and like you could just walk away from
that or you could have been like me and
be an absolute bastard and take out your
bow and arrow and shoot down the last
leaf
oh my god and she just starts crying and
like that's the end of the quest
it's like over in like a minute or
two and it's like this really short
thing and
avor isn't like cassandra or
bayek or edward or ezio like they're not
like someone who belongs in this world
they're not a mercenary working for
money or someone like
connor ezio helping people out of the
goodness of their heart they're kind of
this
invader they're this person who doesn't
really belong and they're just passing
through and the only thing they stop for
are these short little things that are
like
ah this seems kind of interesting or it
could prove like beneficial to me in
some way
and they kind of experience it and move
on there's none of these like really
long
lengthy side quests where avor gets
invested in
like it's the main mission that avor
cares about these like side stuff that
they run into are kind of just
there and you can choose to participate
or
ignore it and i'm not entirely
sure whether or not i like it i liked
the really long
quest that we got in odyssey i liked
meeting the really weird characters and
see cassandra be like really sassy and
snarky with all of them
but at the same time i can see the
benefit of having like
really short two to ten minute quests
that are like
oh yeah did you run into the random
snake lady that farted in your face and
it's like and then two people have a
laugh and they're like oh yeah i totally
remember that like that's something that
you will
never forget yeah and i mean honestly
after having played so many assassin's
creed games a lot of the side stuff
does tend at least for me to kind of i
just don't remember it they've never
really been
that many side pieces of content that i
would describe as being really memorable
and so i'm interested to see like if
they are just to get more wacky with it
and make things that you know people are
going to be talking about i wonder if
you know red dead redemption 2 maybe was
an inspiration in that regard because it
seemed like
even though that side stuff happened to
so many people it was the stuff that you
know we would come into the office and
talk about it's like oh did you see this
guy
like he got bit by a snake and i helped
him out or that you know did you get
ambushed like by the guy hanging
but it's interesting you brought up ivor
as
an outsider because that was one thing i
wanted to talk to you about is because
looking at the footage at least
especially in all of the
pre-release stuff that ubisoft
themselves has been releasing it's been
very action focused
um but whereas one of the core pillars
of assassin's creed
is being that sneaky assassin and i feel
like i haven't been
a sneaky boy or girl and i feel like i
haven't really had the chance
to see how that'll work but
you know you're saying that avor is this
outsider
surely that kind of lends itself more to
being a sneaky sneak
yeah it's it's this weird thing where
you're this badass warrior whenever
you're running around and doing
stuff like that doing missions and story
stuff but when you go
into town it's like a war's a viking
vikings weren't welcome in england
during this
time so when you go into town
sometimes you'll go into a town that
you're friendly with and it's like oh
avor can just
walk around but before you've built that
trust there are now these
new areas like distrust areas that
they're not quite to the whole
red areas from previous assassin's creed
games where it's like oh you're
if you are spotted you're just going to
get into a fight immediately in these
new like towns and cities that you find
yourself in ever puts on a cloak
puts up their hood very assassinate and
they basically have to
make sure that they don't draw any
attention to
themselves like if you stand too close
to someone someone will kind of look at
you
funny and if guards notice you they'll
be like
that person kinda looks like they're
carrying weapons and has
tattoos and battle scars and they look
like a viking maybe we should like
do something about it and so a lot of
the
kind of old og assassin's creed like
stealth mechanics are back like there
are traveling
monks that you can use to blend in with
you can sit on
benches to hide from guards and it feels
very stealthy like i know that a lot of
the
trailers haven't shown this aspect of
the game but for people who are worried
the stealth element
is still there in some capacity i don't
know if it's as
major a component i didn't notice as
many cities
in the preview that i got to play but
there are cities and you have to be very
very careful when you enter them because
you're not
welcome there and there are even brand
new stealth mechanics that haven't been
in assassin's creed games before my
favorite one is the fact that if you
find someone who's drunk
you can promise them it's like hey hey i
i have alcohol
and the dude's like oh sure i'll follow
you anywhere he'll just drunkenly follow
you throughout the entire town
and then if you turn around and become a
bastard and be like i
i don't actually have any alcohol then
like any drunk person would
they'll get super belligerent and start
screaming and shouting and like
cussing at you and that will attract
guards to their position
the guards will be like who the hell is
this drunk dude just screaming over here
and it'll allow you to safely pass by
like a
underpass that they're regarding or
something like that so there are still
there is stealth elements the stealth is
still there and i think it's actually
almost a little bit
more nerve-wracking than before because
you can't walk around
most cities just normally anymore you're
always being watched and you always have
to be careful of
who can see you and from where can they
see you sounds like a really interesting
mix of
old assassin's creed mixed with a bunch
of new ideas
and you know as a long-term assassin's
creed fan that does excite me i always
enjoy it when they kind of try and mix
up the formula a little bit but
overall like what was your final big
takeaway from this final bit of hands-on
that you managed to do
i think my biggest takeaway from all of
this is that
assassin's creed is still
changing i know that there are a bunch
of people who are very traditionalists
and they dislike the fact that
assassin's creed
has evolved and changed so much
since the days of ezio and connor and
edward and i think valhalla
is proof that ubisoft is still trying to
experiment with assassin's creed to find
a brand
new identity with it it started with
origins with the introduction of the new
combat and
odyssey kind of pulled that forward with
a bigger focus on rpg mechanics but i
think valhalla
with the introduction of the settlement
and brand new areas where you have to
interact with the environment in new
ways
is further pushing the genre towards an
open world rpg structure similar to
something like
witcher or dragon age or something like
that
and i don't know if it'll work out it
seems to be working in certain areas
there are aspects of it that i'm like
i'm not quite sure how this is but i
think valhalla is
experimental in very subtle ways and
whether fans like it or not i think this
is a new direction for assassin's creed
and valhalla showcases
what's going to be what future
assassin's creed games are going to look
like
i'm like my interest is totally piqued
uh if you want to see
more from assassin's creed valhalla make
sure to head over to gamespot.com
jordan has written up his impressions
from his
vast amounts of time that he spent with
the game
i thank you so much for watching we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you